ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show my voice is uh slightly
uh uh
it's suffering right now
um
we are here with lex friedman who is an
incredibly intelligent
podcaster researcher he has a podcast
that has probably right now there's i
don't know that you can find a podcast
with better guests than yours
if you look at your ability to get
top-tier people in every field
predominantly the things you're
interested in robotics technology
science physics but you get everybody i
mean you've had richard dawkins you just
had elon musk how do you get
the top people
in those fields and they love coming on
and talking to you
yeah it's an interesting question i
think
if there's one
universal thing that i've noticed is um
somebody close to those folks
is just a fan of the podcast so it's
like this momentum that keeps going
and uh oftentimes it's family members
where they say you know dad or mom or
whatever this guy's
yeah
uh this guy is uh all about love and
it's kind of an idiot and it's fun to
talk to so and then it just kind of
builds like that with elon i a few folks
were fans of the lectures i was giving
at mit and so it's like somebody always
recommends it to them
right and then some of it is also just
networking like um i just know a lot of
people in the tech space and but usually
it's it's funny
for some of these busy folks
it's just somebody close to them
somebody they trust somebody they like
will say hey you should do this kind of
podcast and that because you you find a
lot of really busy people don't
they're very uh they don't know anything
about podcasts
yeah and they're wary of it right
they're wary of sitting down with
somebody they may not know and where
that'll go and what they'll end up
saying especially a lot of people that
are in positions of power
usually
they're you know i spent time with the
ceo of nbc once for a day
um they were doing a sketch
an internal sketch to be played at their
board meeting and they hired me as a
comedic actor to play a cab driver
uh in the sketch yeah and the whole
sketch was going to be the ceo of nbc
universal he was no longer the ceo but
he was steve something or other he was
going to roast
the
uh board the people you know his people
he was going to roast them in a playful
fun way
and i was going to be the cab driver and
they spent tens of thousands of dollars
maybe more
um the you know the cab was on a dolly
it was being carted around new york
now
what amazed me about spending like a few
hours with him was how tightly
structured his entire life is yeah how
many he had a lawyer with him at all
times he had a personal assistant with
him at all times nbc universal had an
attorney there
the script which was such a simple
script had gone through 10 or 15
rewrites and redrafts um
and he was a very intelligent guy and
his time had such a premium
it had such value
that to say to anybody in that space
come and spend two hours with me and
just let it fly like i remember the
first thing i saw when i
uh the first thing i said when i saw him
he walked out and he goes you're the cab
driver and i said yup
last white cab driver in new york and he
went whoa whoa that's not in the script
right i said no no no he goes okay
that's and he's looking at like his
lawyers and his people he's like wait a
minute we're not gonna say that right
so
it's very interesting
that
you you you have these people that come
on and and they feel comfortable enough
with you
to just
and speak everything you described with
the situation you were in to me is
toxic for a great conversation so 100
i'm becoming so one of the the deeper
question here is is how do you talk to
these people for two three four hours
and how do you make sure that nobody
else is allowed in the room like i have
to vet anyone who's allowed so no
marketing people no people that have a
notebook and they're taking notes right
about the things you're not supposed to
say where they look over is that
appropriate none of those people
sometimes it's cool to have
uh just friends
who just make so you can look over them
and laugh like ben's here you can look
over and left that's great but
i
at you maybe in the first like few dozen
conversations i was okay with like
people being present but now i'm like
hardcore
uh you started three hours it has to be
three hours yes is the joe rogan
inspired that you could do long-form
conversation with your friends and then
say like
it's polite of course and respectful but
saying
i have different ways of saying it but
like
i feel most comfortable creatively
right
with just us two and then absolutely and
and uh
okay well yeah there's and then there's
the uncomfortable like
pressure saying like i know what the
hell i'm doing and that those that exact
conversation has
come up which is ultimately you have to
trust me that i know what the hell i'm
doing
and then i would bring out the best in
this person what's interesting about you
we talked about a little bit before
uh
we started is that you you don't own
real estate you don't own a property you
rent you like the freedom of that yes
and by the way to sorry to interrupt
your conversation with joe about digital
real estate yeah quite epic i think i
think it was interesting yeah and i
think a lot of people responded to it
yeah you
right now real life and people tell me
all the time they go are you kidding
or are you serious and i go
real life right now is living on that
line
yeah the things that are real
sound like comedy yeah
so
i'm talking to joe and i'm being funny
because that's what i try to do but i'm
also bringing up
real actual trends
that are happening
and
people
i think are so
you know
removed from that world that it all
sounds like comedy and a lot of it is
very funny
but it's actually a real
thing that is happening but you
what's interesting about you is the
concept of ownership in the real world
you view
as kind of a lack of freedom you were
saying yeah i i think
i value
freedom
to make big leaps into the unknown is
exceptionally important so i also value
love and monogamy and relationships all
those kinds of things right those put a
limit on for a lot of people does put a
limit on freedom right i don't see it
that way so like i think people use that
as an excuse in the same way house
ownership
people often use as an excuse
to get complacent to
to limit themselves so i i don't think a
how i don't think ownership in itself is
a limit on your freedom but people get
comfortable they get soft it becomes a
limitation because i want to be able to
tomorrow
say you know i'm going to start a
company and i'm not going to do it in
austin i'm going to do it in kansas city
i'm going to do it in san francisco and
move just
uh walk away yeah cool guys don't look
back at explosions just walk away just
walk away and that that something about
me i mean i don't want to generalize but
for me
i probably won't do that but the freedom
to do that allows you to think
big
to uh take leaps into uh the unknown in
a way that materializes like the best
version of yourself
i i mean i i fully
agree as a person who bought a house
well i i did i did my house i think that
part of what i
like is problems
yes problems are essential for my
business
um what's your business exactly uh
uh it's a great question um
i think it it it's um
you know in in his very simplest form
it's um
making people happy
right that's like the simplest way to
say it
and if there are no problems there's
never going to be a reason to make
anyone happy that's why utopians hate
comedy because they think you can create
a world in which there will be no pain
so if there is no pain there's no reason
to alleviate that pain through comedy
but i'm someone who realizes that no
matter how great you make the world
you're gonna have pain you're gonna have
problems so one of the reasons that i
kind of
like entitlements
problems things like that is because i
see a lot of opportunities in them
to
um
you know release that
valve of pressure
comedically so you lean into the chaos
because from the chaos comes a lot of
problems and then you can
understand the human condition by
analyzing i think that's part of it i
also think i
i have to do things
to know what they are
and part of my job is to hopefully make
those things funny
so by by owning a house
i've i've owned houses that i i mean i
own one house that i lost i'm
very open about that during the mortgage
crisis right so i went through that
and now i bought a house very
responsibly but when you buy a house
very responsibly it's still very much
you know
a
um weight
it's a weight
on you you feel that weight you know
and
but there's value i think to weighing
yourself down sometimes yes
because then
you understand what other people are
going through when i'm in a comedy club
or a theater i'm looking out in the
audience and i'm going all of these
people have that weight they have more
than that they have kids they have
you know
jobs they have
uh
family members they support they have a
lot lots of weight so to understand that
and to relate to that
for me i think there's a value to it but
i also agree with you
and completely understand that it slows
you down
houses are they slow you down families
even though they're amazing and valuable
can have that effect as well and it's
well worth it to be slowed certain times
slowing down i think is worth it but you
also have to be honest with yourself
that the slowing down is often
artificial like if you're it's in your
mind not to be stoic first for a second
but yeah like
there's no reason you can't sell the
house well absolutely some of it is you
want to make sure you get a house you
can actually afford yes all those kinds
of things but and but even still people
talk about like fu money
and they use the lack of money
or insufficient amount of money as an
excuse to stay in the job they don't
like stay in the life they don't like
stay in the marriage they don't like
stay in a house they don't like when in
reality you could i think it's an excuse
like most people can take the bold
action it's a huge risk but take a leap
into the unknown get rid of the house
and go pursue a job that you actually
love and then everything else yeah will
just uh
everything do you think everybody loves
something
so this is see this is a fundamental
disagreement that we have
they have the capacity to discover
something they love yes
that's a different thing so if you think
that there's nothing in this world you
love outside of chemical depression so
if you
if you if there's just the chemistry
that makes you incapable of seeing some
aspect of beauty in the world i think
everybody could discover it and it's a
little
flame that's in everybody that you just
uh
haven't ever met stupid people
i think part of when i speak to you i
speak to a guy
who's because he's very smart has had
the privilege of speaking to some very
very intelligent people but have you
ever spoken to someone who is not that
smart and i don't mean a bad person
i don't mean a a malevolent human being
in any way i mean someone who's not
complex they're a simple yeah person i
love so let me just make clear
that i don't like the quote-unquote
intelligent people or the elite people
or the rich people i like simple people
simple people people i that's my i see
myself as a you say i'm yeah but you're
not but this is when this is what i'm
gonna this is the you've got a robot on
your floor you interviewed the richest
man in the world yesterday this is when
we have to stop you're wearing a suit
it's it's it's 12. i mean rogan thinks
he's a simple man too he owns the
colorado river can we stop this is when
as a comedian i have to point out how
insane this sounds to everyone you're a
brilliant guy you give lectures at mit
you're just not a simple person i was in
bucky's yesterday you know what bucky's
is it's a walmart competitor
and and bucky is a beaver and and and
it's a big walmart and people go into it
and they buy everything they need and
they have bucky's nuggets and they're
like corn pops cereal they're not good
for you they're like potato chips
essentially they're like you know this
highly processed sugar food and they're
so popular people go to buckies and they
buy the nuggets and they eat the bucky's
nuggets on their couch yeah don't you
understand that those people
fundamentally have some differences with
you
no i mean okay i just don't think so i
think they
are more like they they appreciate life
more actually than the the
true the people who are in this rat race
of like
trying so the quote-unquote smart people
are the people who are climbing some
kind of uh yes treat like careers said
to some of those people do what you love
they might say i'm doing what i love i
love the bucky's nuggets yeah and i love
my couch first of all that yes
if they
well okay so i wanted to be a
psychiatrist when i was growing up so i
would have to have
like several months worth of sessions
with them to discuss is it truly what
they i think on session two
you would realize that you're kind of
going up against a brick wall no i don't
know not everybody is meant to live this
fully
um
you know like examined life many people
are quite happy
it doesn't have to be examined you don't
have to be you don't have to read
philosophical literature it can just be
honest with yourself like self-reflect
yes in a simple way about what the hell
do you love about life well that's
that's fair and i'm with you on that
yeah i'm with you on that what i think
is what we've done as a society in my
estimation this is one of our
fundamental disagreements we agree on
many things
um you mean you and i i think we agree
on a lot yes but then there's things we
disagree on like such as well i think
love
no love is important and essential i
have to talk to you about relationships
we'll do we'll do that in a second but
one of the things where me and you have
a
disagreement is this very vague and
general advice that we give to people we
tell them your life
is not
valid or meaningful unless you have this
dream
that you uh or this deep love
of something that you have to pursue
and you have to be on this journey
and to me
i know people that derive a lot of
happiness from the greatest
uh simplicities in their life
um whether that might be uh you know and
i'm not saying family is simple but it
might be just having a family it might
be
just
being sober
it might be just having enough money to
pay the rent so to me to tell everybody
that
there's a um that they have to love
something
in a way
that motivates them or inspires them
to chase it or follow it
i think it's a very
it's a very it's incomplete yeah as
advice yeah maybe uh like if there's a
goal that you have to reach for you have
to improve like new year's resolution
style goal sure yeah no i uh
i i was like you know these great guys
these david goggins and all these people
are running backwards on a mountain yes
totally get it right i mean that's great
who is that for like i know it's for
people
like
the the people that run up the hill
are gonna run up the hill
the people that aren't gonna run up the
hill aren't now sometimes the people
that aren't running up the hill will
decide to run up the hill for me the
positive aspect of david goggins is it
wakes you up to consider
do i want to be a david goggins in this
world or do i want to be something else
like it just it just like shakes you up
like looking at weirdness
like that's a good point like just
looking at something that's completely
out of the ordinary right i mean you
could just look at any kind of weird
video i suppose of a human being doing
anything weird and then it reminds you
wait a minute so people can are capable
of this
so maybe i'm capable of a lot of stuff
what am i actually interested in i was
just having a conversation with somebody
um
and uh older women i've been practicing
russian i've been speaking in russian
with
with uh folks what's interesting about
you is they hired you at the fsb without
even speaking russian yeah they just let
you yeah that's odd they just said
you'll figure it out yeah yeah they have
a whole program yeah to get you up to
speed fair enough so i was talking to
her and she said the thing that brings
her happiness
is uh
like
this is gonna sound a little bit strange
but so making dinner for her family
putting everybody to bed just three kids
like her husband uh is like waiting for
her in bed or he might be already
sleeping and just sitting there at the
kitchen table
oh also making a breakfast and lunch for
the next day for the kids and just
everything is done
everything is clean everything is
perfect and she's just sitting at the
kitchen table and realizing this is
happiness right and that to me was like
yeah that's another way of happiness and
i i am the same way to me like
i mean
one form of happiness is just being
pretty good
at whatever i take on so like uh i don't
know organizing any kind of stuff i love
organizing right you couldn't tell it by
this place but like i have an ocd nature
and it makes me feel good
to um to organize stuff like
spreadsheets or data and all those kinds
of things right
i could you know people talk [ __ ] about
uh desk
you know uh office work but i would love
that i would love to be an excel person
right organized or you know what like
somebody's assistant
where i like schedule stuff i love
scheduling things you like that yeah i
love it i would uh yeah you were talking
about love earlier yeah and you were
saying it's uh
what what are your thoughts on that as a
organizing principle of
people's lives
and when you see people in relationships
he's very interesting to me i know
people that i think are genuinely in
love like i think ben and his wife are
genuinely in love but i also see other
relationships
that are business arrangements
and they're also successful
truly so
yeah so that's very interesting yeah
partnerships that's right that's
different from love so
so broadly first of all love to me is
much bigger than romantic love of course
so
you have to put friendship like ever
since i was young
i was at a longing for other human
beings and that connection you have you
you mentioned like uh
sort of uh you know happiness is is
contrasted to the
the suffering or whatever the hardship
that people are going through and that's
kind of your job put yourself in a place
of hardship so you can make people happy
but i i always saw that there's just uh
unfairness and cruelty and all that kind
of stuff in the world and you could just
huddle like penguins together
amidst that and that's what friendship
is but aside from humans also
there's just
like
it's sitting at the kitchen table or
like looking out at a tree in nature and
just appreciating to be alive that to me
is love like that connection yes to just
[ __ ] it's good to be alive that feeling
that yeah but romantic love
i just have seen um
just over and over and over again
hanging out with uh rogan and david
goggins in vegas just uh hanging out
with their wives
and seeing like
holy [ __ ]
so much of their success has to do with
with these people and their relationship
that's a huge component and so like i've
interacted with a lot of successful
people where i don't think it's an
accident where there's this belief in
each other excitement for each other and
it's like you also realize that
what the hell are you doing in this
force to your point like what are we
trying to teach people i think
i think success
is is tastes the best feels the best
when you get to share with people you
love yes and that's 100
and that's you know so to me that seems
to be essential for a happy life is
having a like a inner circle a small
collection of people that you just love
getting excited about [ __ ] together with
that is absolutely true and sometimes
they're you know the opposite sex or the
same sex whatever they are then you have
sex with them yes for many years right
and let me ask you an interesting
question that's how that works in your
estimation i look at
jeffrey and jaslane and i say they were
in love
that was a a very deep and powerful love
i see the same
i look at you and ben the same way
absolutely yeah he's the just slain we
are not as successful you're the jeffrey
as jeffrey and just lane
yeah but
what i mean about that right is you have
this
from the outside world it's a very
interesting conversation right
because everything you just said is
beautiful and true but let's look at the
other side of that
so to us
you have jeffrey anders lane they're
having this amazing love affair they
genuinely deeply love each other do you
think so by the way it seems so okay
right i mean the way they look at each
other
i mean they they really truly seemed
to to love and trust each other yeah
right they built this empire
and
nothing bonds you like doing evil on the
world true
so my question is
is that valid
the love that they have for each other
because it does check a lot of the boxes
of what you talked about where it's like
huddling together
um you know it's us against the world
yeah
is that a valid love yeah it it is it is
but it it can blind you to such to to
where you can do evil like the harm
you're doing to others like love of
nation is something i also have right i
which nation
that's funny you should ask no uh of
course man i'm i'm american
through which is what i would say on a
podcast that's going to be televised
live in austin texas nothing more
american than that exactly it's it's it
really sells i believe
um i you're shooting guns now i'm gonna
start wearing a cowboy hat just to make
people
believe and uh can we edit out the part
where i said we're i talk russian
because that's gonna be uh that's not
gonna fit the brand of what i'm trying
to sell here
no uh
you know you grow up in the soviet union
where the idea i grew up in the soviet
union where the idea of love of country
was really powerful and so much of it is
propaganda but there was a you know
literally the national anthem said
ironically enough were the greatest
country on earth indestructible it is
the greatest the soviet anthem is the
greatest anthem ever written i played in
the car with pen it is the most powerful
you want to talk about musical yeah
prowess i mean it's amazing and i don't
know you should look at the lyrics
because they say we're indestructible
there's a
you know the american national anthem
is kind of polite yes it's proud it's
beautiful yeah the soviet national
anthem is like we're the baddest
[ __ ] on this planet right you
will never destroy us of course it
collapsed yeah so there you go that they
changed it quickly they changed the
national anthem after that but so that's
a love of country
hitler is an example of somebody that
very effectively sold the love of
country right so love
doesn't necessarily
create good in the world right it's this
is more kind of um because love is a
very powerful force a blinding force
yeah when you talk about propaganda in
the soviet union you've lived in both
countries
you've seen american
propaganda you've seen soviet propaganda
how does american propaganda function
differently or does it
than
what you uh remember growing up in the
soviet union
maybe you could speak to
what you see as propaganda because
there's so many
beautiful flavors of propaganda sure in
the united states what i remember from
the soviet union there's a
uh centralized
government-driven propaganda so it's
it's more boring right capitalism does
everything great even the propaganda
right so so i would i guess i would
define it kind of loosely
as um
the way that narratives emerge and are
sustained in a society those narratives
could be about
the society itself they could be about
the way that society interacts with
other societies uh but that to be
is the most enduring form of of
propaganda is
basically
these
specific belief systems that we have
that are sustained through
our media
hollywood
uh
athletics sports things like that
yeah i it's incomparable to me so you
could say like the mainstream media for
a long time was a was an arm of the
propaganda machine or something like
that because they would create
narratives uh maybe
like going to war and afghanistan and
iraq
that was uh created through propaganda
right you can make all those kinds of
arguments but ultimately in the united
states the freedom of speech is obvious
the not just the actual
institutions that enable freedom of
speech but the desire in each human
heart in each american like the
obsession with the individualist
freedom right is like um insatiable so
it's it's amazing to watch actually and
so
it like propaganda takes
weird
forms here there's just a lot of
competing narratives and there's battles
and then you realize
something like alex jones can make a lot
of money with one narrative then there's
like cnn can make a lot of money with
another narrative and so it's a
competition of narratives which ones go
viral right and all so ultimately though
it doesn't feel
like centralized control
in the way the soviet union did where
everybody legitimately believed
this the story told in the united states
because of the competing narratives i i
feel like everybody is
constantly skeptical about anything
you're very cynical and skeptical to me
it feels like
the centralized control is not for lack
of trying like the lack of centralized
control yeah is not for lack of trying
it feels like you have this carcass this
this dead animal by the side of the road
which is the media
and you have vultures
i'm one of them that are taking a little
bit of it yeah and the animals may be
still alive and it's moaning and going
and those moans are
the stories you get um
it does feel like this was a centralized
um so the centralized effort is the dead
animal on the side of the road yeah and
you're the vultures we're the people the
freedom of the the we're the people
by coming in and saying hey
we possess the technology
and the ambition
to also have a voice in a in a in a very
crowded space where a lot of people want
a voice um
but i i think you're you're absolutely
right but what i see with with tech tech
there's a real danger
that we can re-centralize meaning that
you have very few companies that have an
enormous amount of power
and you have a lot of different um
people and a lot of different beliefs
and narratives
you know
every institution somebody said this
once and i believe that
every institution
seeks power through control
and that's something that i've seen
with the kovid over the last 12 months
you've seen people get banned
you've seen people have their accounts
frozen they've been demonetized they've
lost careers they've lost their ability
to speak
because they've had a different
opinion and a different view
yeah robert malone robert was banned
yesterday yeah though from uh from
twitter this is one of the creators of
the mrna vaccine right
i don't know why we can't live in a
society where robert malone is allowed
to have an opinion
i don't know why we can't live in a
society where
joe rogan is allowed to have an opinion
right i mean he is now right i mean yeah
but
just to clarify you want him to be
banned who joe rogan
well i i think the way you state made
that sound sound oh interesting i wasn't
sure if you were doing the joke no no no
i you know seeing people coming
that clip yeah
well joe's show's not big so i don't
think it needs to be banned
when you get to a certain level i'm
surprised you're not banned yet they
will net well it's interesting you do
know i i know jack dorsey pretty well
so yeah i don't think jack's the problem
he's not he's
i think he's like this libertarian guy
with a beard
who actually does believe in free speech
twitter was the freest of all of these
now i think zuckerberg's a problem
i think he's isolated truly i think the
people in his
in his group are a problem
and i think
um
can ask a question yeah actually so
on zuckerberg yeah because i have the
same kind of intuition but
um
like
how do we know for sure because it feels
like some of it is also narratives that
i call because he wants to be a good guy
and i think if you want to be a good guy
and you want the world to see you at all
times as a good guy
you're going to be very malleable
and if you don't have values that are
set in stone
um
at any given time i mean look at the
last year yeah in the beginning of the
last year mentioning that the virus came
from maybe potentially from a lab in
china made you a hysterical racist some
crazy reactionary now
it's a
pretty well established reasonable
hypothesis that's only in 12 months
you've seen
voicing that opinion go from
exiled from polite society to
pretty reasonable rational mainstream
belief
now
if you believe in freedom of speech
you ride that wave
and you say you're allowed to have this
opinion and you're allowed to have this
opinion if you're looking to be a good
guy well back there you're going that
opinion is not allowed but then a year
later you go we'll allow it now so if
you're constantly
going with
taking the temperature
of of public opinion
and and these institutions that are
around you and when i say public opinion
i don't even mean the public i mean
the small set of people that really
define public discourse that's my worry
about zuckerberg is that he wants to be
seen as good all the time and he wants
to be liked all the time and that can
cause you to
to
but a lot of us
a lot of us want to be liked right true
i i want to be a good person but not all
we don't own facebook so the point is
that my aunt wants to be liked all the
time but she's unemployed
so when you have when you control one of
the most
massive exchanges of information in the
world
i don't you know you having a basic
human trait yeah
can be a lot more
uh dangerous than
a comedian having it who has very little
power
you know in terms of
yeah so your sense is that
anybody in mark zuckerberg's position
your ability to
truly have a good sense of who you are
and what reality is it gets corrupted
yeah i think that's why jack probably
left twitter he's like he maybe sensed
that something i think jack was
basically like i can't do it anymore and
again i'm speaking completely out of
turn i've never
met him
um or spoken to him but what i what i do
think is that he
from my belief system did believe in
things now it doesn't mean
everything he believed in
uh you know his company did not behave
that way all the time i don't think they
executed always
but i think i think there was some
overarching belief
in the freedom of people to exchange
their opinions
now that started to get curbed later in
his tenure and now he's gone and it
scares me what's coming next so i think
so sort of uh
the belief in the freedom of speech
is an interesting one and as a platform
because they have a lot of videos of
rape violence being uploaded and they
have so they have to remove something
from the platform that's right and it
becomes a slippery slope for every
platform which they realize every social
media platform even the ones that
advocate freedom of speech they have a
line that you if you cross you don't
absolutely i think
chan was the one that was created that
said like
we're saying there's no line but i think
even they had a line and that was a big
thing well i i believe there should be a
line right i mean in terms of like child
pornography rape
uh violence scenes of gratuitous
violence right
threatening people
to a point you know doxing people
putting out their personal information
encouraging harm yeah right there are
all these lines that in a society we
need to have
what i don't know
uh i don't think those lines should
necessarily be political
and i think that's what i've seen more
and more of i i think uh
my biggest problem is sort of uh
determining lines from a place of
arrogance versus humility so i really
like it when people
kind of approach all of this
with the d with a high degree of
uncertainty about how much they truly
understand the world so the to me the
problem is isn't the drawing of a line
it's the drawing of a line with
arrogance like as if you know better and
so i mean you could see
reasonably that
uh quote-unquote misinformation about a
pandemic
could be viewed in a in a boardroom at
facebook or whatever social media
company as something that could lead to
the death of millions right so from
their perspective they could say all
right well we want to stop the spread of
misinformation so we're going to censor
everything that uses the word ivamectin
or something like that right
but
you have to have a humility that wait a
minute maybe we don't perfectly
know what
are the solutions to this pandemic we
need to keep be open-minded here maybe
very specific figures in the scientific
community aren't the sole possessors of
the truth even the scientific
institutions themselves maybe they're
not the sole possessors or the truth
right and having the arrogance about
that is is really dangerous so to me i
think so so the reason i'm bringing all
this up is
i hope it's possible to be
at the scale of facebook at the scale of
twitter
and
have the humility
to
actually have a like a product that does
good for the world right like constantly
ask itself wait a minute are we doing
the right thing here as opposed to kind
of having very specific metrics about
engagements and those kinds of things
that uh what in your estimation did uh
is is there
intact just like every business the
monopolies are so inevitable seemingly
like we have all these smart people in
america we have all these
you know capable people in tech
but
all of these massive whether it's amazon
or facebook
there's really five companies that
control everything and it seems to be
that's going to be the way that it'll be
forever
and does
you disagree okay well that's good i
would love it to change it's a new it's
a new uh so tech everything we see with
the internet is new
there's another generation of people
coming up
that
are i i would place the problem and
it's complicated but let me try to
explain i think one of it has to do with
money so what happens is
uh like these big companies they acquire
with the moment you become successful
they start acquiring you and to me one
of the things
that i value like for me
uh i i have a dream of starting a
company and i know for sure i will never
sell that company so you have to believe
in your idea
and that's there's a lot of
entrepreneurs that i see now that really
believe in an idea and in that way you
can build
a larger number of companies that create
a market of ideas and how you can do
social media how you can do
whatever we're talking about
how you can do uh platforms that show
video platforms that show images all
those kinds of things and then you could
have a competition in terms of
censorship in terms of how data is
stored and shared how much transparency
there is about the data so i have a
hope for that
uh so i don't think it always has to be
that way
one of the problems is that just
facebook keeps acquiring everything that
uh that comes up so when companies uh
sell
they just lose control and whatever that
initial idea was
gets uh potentially perverted
to fit
someone else's idea or someone else's
profit model
and there's a kind of complacency
with uh within big companies where they
don't they lose track
of uh what made them great in the first
place which is constantly questioning
are we doing the right thing how can we
do this better right so that urgency you
have when you're going to go bankrupt if
you do make the wrong decision that's
what startups have and uh you can't you
can never lose that urgency that's what
steve jobs was great at artificially or
not creating urgency like we need to
constantly create a new idea constantly
yes and those people are rare and elon
is an example of somebody that i do
think that
one of the you know the the weaknesses i
think of the pro free speech
contingent of people is they don't
appreciate the complexity of the issue
like it is very difficult yeah like all
the things we talked about violence
against children uh you know threatening
things making people's home addresses
available like there is a lot of gray
area there always has been so i
certainly don't envy the job that
somebody like a jack dorsey has right
um i don't envy mark zuckerberg's job
you know these people are dealing with
foreign manipulation they're dealing
with bad actors in their space they're
dealing with organized troll campaigns
directed from other places so i don't
envy that it's an insanely difficult
thing to do especially because we are
living more and more online
more and more people
their ability to earn a living their
ability to market themselves to
companies all rests on their ability to
have a a digital identity
so when you look at
this stuff you go
it's you know and all these you know
things it's all these like q and on um
networks that start you know parlor and
all these things that are like you know
explicitly political uh and they go well
if you're off twitter you can go on
parlor but then you go on parliament
you're like okay this is looney tunes
right you're going into this crazy
bubble yeah you're going into this crazy
uh bubble where a lot of things are just
not
based in reality at all it's a hard
problem to solve because it's hard you
could see like parlor you could have
hope like okay here's a place where
freedom of speech reigns and then you
look there and it's like it's just a
bunch of hate and it's not even fun to
hang out there it's right so you go
you need a little bit of hate you need a
little bit of hey this is my new
campaign it's called a little bit of
hate you know a lot of people are
getting rid of hate wholesale in the
schools
and i believe i should go back and just
go we need a little bit of hate that's
your ted talk yeah it's like a little
bit of hate you need a little bit of
hate you need a little bit of
you know
um
contention you need people
who have different ideas to be able to
fight it out a little bit without
completely saying you have to use this
service and you have to use that service
you know but it's tough it's difficult
you know tom weiss's yeah of course got
that song um i like my town with a
little drop of poison yeah
i think that's true i actually kind of
see you as that person in the tavern i
think it's in shrek yeah where there's
like an old man and a tavern playing a
piano right he's got he's got a voice
kind of like yours yeah she's like
you're raspy yeah over time becoming
more and more tom waits that's very true
my final form is tom brades
my final form is is a piano
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time they
are 35 more than 50 million men in the
us suffer from male pattern baldness
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both okay
keeps is something that a lot of people
i know have had great success with they
offer a simple stress-free way to keep
your hair convenient verch convenient
virtual doctors consultations and
medications delivered straight to your
door every three months you don't have
to leave your house low cost treatments
are only ten dollars per month they
start there
keeps offers generic versions of the fda
approved uh inc uh big uh hair
treatment
medications on the market discreet
packaging and proven results keebs has
more five-star reviews than any of his
competitors prevention is key
treatments could take four to six months
to see results so act fast okay
so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dillon to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon to
get your first month free k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash tyndall and you'll get your
first month free and you'll be on your
way to
hair
you'll be on your way to saving your
better help everybody's mental
everybody's mentally unwell and their
their brain has been shattered
you need help so get better help better
help they are hiring more counselors
everywhere because you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not self-help this is
professional counseling done securely
online there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log in your account
anytime lex and send a message to your
counselor i love them by the way they're
creators i use better help you can get
timely and is that a robot going nuts
you can get timely he needs help too
yeah
you can get timely and thoughtful
responses from your counselor you start
communicating so quickly everybody loves
if you don't like your counselor you
could just switch to another one it's
not a big deal it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today visit their website
and read their testimonials that are
posted daily okay betterhelp.com reviews
so visit betterhelp.com timd that's
betterhlp and join over one million
people who've taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using betterhelp they
are recruiting so many new additional
counselors to meet the demand this
podcast is sponsored by better health
and timberland show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
tim d
what do you think the challenges are
um for
um
because you have this new internet web
three yeah as they call it right digital
tokens
crypto
um are you a believer in this are you a
skeptic what i mean web 3 or crypto
well
it's a good that's a good delineation
web 3 is not something to believe in or
not right i mean that's just kind of
here do you believe that crypto is going
to be this force that helps things
decentralize
or do you believe that absolutely
absolutely yeah so you know i've had a
lot of conversations about
cryptocurrency
all the so i i could give you the full
sort of uh rundown of all the different
cryptocurrencies that are exciting to me
but to me personally
zero of it has to do with money so i uh
like financial
um
what do you call it investment right so
a lot of people that's part of the
problems the space is a lot of people
just want to make money and they they
want to make a quick buck so they they
their excitement is exaggerated
by the fact that they're invested in a
particular coin and so to me what's
interesting is the different
technologies involved and they're
amazing so explain briefly to people
that are unaware of what blockchain
technology is because
maybe they have not come in contact with
anyone
who has
made it their business to yell at them
for 10 hours about it well it's a pretty
tough task uh maybe one
[Music]
nice way to do it is just to mention
some of the key technologies that are
competing
so
the original implementation of
cryptocurrency on a blockchain is
bitcoin
and uh one of the defining aspects of it
is this proof of work so it's very
difficult
um it's it's it's grounded to physical
reality in the way that gold is grounded
to physical reality and that's really
powerful
and uh also it's powerful because no
governments
can control it
and so there's a
there's a finite amount of it and
there's a finite amount of it still so
the scarcity is enforced so it's going
to hold its value there's a lot of nice
properties to it
and then uh the negative side is the
transactions are very slow and expensive
so
um people have constructed like layer
two technologies which is using bitcoin
for
the the great things that bitcoin does
and having the fast transactions that
you want like if you want to pay for
dinner
they have layer two technologies like
lightning network as an example that
sits on top of bitcoin
okay then there's ethereum with um
now
blockchain is like a
when people talk about a ledger
and what what would they like how would
you break that down to somebody who's
like wait a minute what in god's name
are you talking about uh
so it's a way that all of these
transactions are
um
you know stored yeah so it's basically a
database right it's a way to store data
in a way that cannot be
uh falsified
or um
sort of um
sort of attacked and falsified and faked
and changed by anybody because there's a
lot of people that have a consensus
mechanism that are monitoring and have
full access to that data and that so
blockchain just means
store of data uh that has a
temporal component so it's there's a
sequence to it
and nobody can modify it okay and so
like this is like secure
uh reliable in the way that physical
reality is secure and reliable if you
um
that
if you break a glass it's broken that's
a fact that nobody nobody can unbreak
that glass right and fake it convince
you it never broke right fake news like
that reality happened and
in the same way blockchain
is
the first technology of its kind
that
in a digital space that allows you to
have that same reliability across the
population in the same way that physical
realities is reliable blockchain just
stores information in a reliable way
nobody can mess with it and then
everybody just uses that blockchain
in different ways and there's
uh is there one blockchain or are there
several yeah each one does there's one
per
per uh
per person so ethereum a lot of the nfts
that are selling right now they're on
the ethereum blockchain yes right yeah
and then ethereum has a lot of cool
properties right of course it's evolving
ethereum 2.0 i think
it's supposed to come out 2022 so you
had the founder on your show yeah a
couple times brilliant guy really humble
so uh
oh some of these
some of these cryptocurrencies don't
have one
figurehead they have a community of
people community of developers right
obviously not obviously but it's well
known that uh the bitcoin
uh creator and founder is anonymous uh
satoshi nakamoto right that seems to be
less true every year
yeah more people everybody i wouldn't be
surprised if you are satoshi nakamoto oh
you're saying what people are
seemingly
it's a they're drawing a line around a
group of people it's got to be one of
them right yeah yeah it's not like it
could be anybody
well right but that's the beauty of it
right that's that you don't know and
that's a powerful idea in itself the
anonymity but then vitalik buterin who's
the uh one the co-founder of a theorem
it's kind of like the figurehead and he
represents it and so um and there's
there's a few others like uh another
co-founder of ethereum is uh charles
hoskinson who created cardano that's a
very interesting piece of technology um
also so
there
i would say they're smart contracts
which is
ways to use the blockchain to make
agreements
between people like exchange assets or
to like you know the same kind of
contracts you do between people so
that's really interesting there's uh
uh there's moving away from the proof of
work which requires you to use a lot of
resources explain that explain proof of
work when you said it grounds bitcoin
to the physical reality explain proof of
work proof of work you have to solve a
cryptographic puzzle on a computer so
computer has to do a really hard thing
for a long time to solve it and you have
to have a giant number of computers
doing a giant number of computations so
that's why it takes all this energy it
takes all of this energy yeah but that's
why it's very difficult to fake
it it's very difficult
for
um
a large number of people to get together
and say we're gonna create a bunch of
fake bitcoin so this this really grounds
it you you always have to come back to
this mining effort of performing the
computation
there's another what is it is a math
problem essentially it's a math it's a
simple math problem you just have to do
a lot of it
to get one bitcoin to mine one bitcoin
and how many computers have to do this
as many as you want okay so you you can
be mining bitcoin
with one computer
and it would take a long time to take a
little very long so how many computers
do you need if you want to make quick
work of it it sounds like you're
starting
you're getting ideas in your head uh
maybe i am i think it's getting less and
less
possible to really make money with this
mining effort i'm i'm actually not
paying too much attention of um
with where the major mining facilities
are china recently uh banned
mining uh
bitcoin mining so they banned
cryptocurrency and banned mining so all
the mines that were in china
had to move elsewhere but i think it's
distributed across the world i think
there's in south america there's and and
one of the reasons that elon
um
here in austin sorry to interrupt sure
i'm sure there are
um elon made some news by saying it
needs to be a greener more
environmentally friendly process this is
maybe last year yeah so what the
bitcoins will say what the bitcoin folks
will say is yes it's not environmentally
friendly but the benefit you get far
outweighs the cost
so there's a lot of stuff we do that's
not environmentally friendly driving
cars
eating meat
and their argument is like well the
benefit to society is much higher than
the cost it has in the environment right
so like don't don't just find a
boogeyman
just because you want
it did they just see it as another way
to attack bitcoin okay
but yes it's bad for the environment but
so are a lot of things absolutely the
argument that would make because this
has the opportunity to revolutionize
the monetary system across the world so
one of the downsides
of um
the way money is used in the world is
used by governments to control the
populace that's right there's a lot of
people that talk about authoritarian
regimes
that um
that that you know use inflation you use
money to control people and so bitcoin
allows you to start wars it's just our
words do everything and so to fund
gain of function research into diseases
and then leak out yeah okay allegedly
uh
um i i've been thinking about whether i
want to talk to fauci i really don't i
really he's not gonna come on
he will do you think he'll come on yeah
so this was a discussion here he said
yes but the problem is
he wants to do 15 minutes
so he doesn't know who i am
or anybody it's the same podcast problem
and i said no has to be three hours and
so
um because i do this is one example of a
person again that has a lot of
not again but there's a lot of positive
aspects to him that he's he's
accomplished a lot of incredible things
in his life he and he started aids
i mean that's a huge thing that was a
big deal yeah it's very impactful hitler
was i think man of the century for the
20th century killed beagles
hitler did no voucher
your friend
he's not my friend
uh and then him and bill gates
recently pizza
what well i don't know about that okay
but
bill gates is buying up all the farmland
what's the connection between fiochi and
and
there must be a disease freaks
yeah they like diseases a little too
much yeah there's listen i understand
when you spend your life researching
pandemics you get a little they're a
little too excited about it it's
nietzsche if you if you gaze into the
abyss
that this raises back into you voucher's
also an italian
that's they have many problems that's
the first big problem they have many
defects yeah um and that's more suited
to make
pizza
or
be a maitre d at a restaurant yeah than
he is to be a scientist yeah
it makes perfect sense italians are not
men italians are criminals and they're
meant to be in
so wherever they are they're going to
commit crime
so if they're in a pizzeria and it's a
cash business they can steal some of the
money and feel good about themselves but
when they're put in the government they
can steal so much money that they can
have too much power so fauci is a
problem yeah
primarily because he's italian that's
true well it's a huge part of it but
he's a power crazed
um uh vaccine hitler
um
go back to the uh
ethereum and the uh yeah and uh
get a canary into coal mine
uh let me just wrap up the foul yeah
just to to quickly say that i do think
as a political leader in the response to
this pandemic he he did a terrible job
he to me does not represent science
uh there is a lot of good things to say
about him but none of those things come
to mind from me i think he's in the
pandemic he did a poor job responding to
the pandemic but i think he did a really
good job starting it
yeah yeah yeah i um tim dillon speaking
here
uh
something hitler
um it was it was beautifully it was
poetic the way he referred to him as
hitler i forgot me
yeah
hitler vaccine hitler thank you that was
that was very good oh we should have
four shots five shots
six shots
i like to study diseases and then we
like to leak them into the population
and see what happens and then bill and
melinda gates get divorced because
bill's on epstein's island
i thought she didn't even get invited to
absolute island that's how big of a
loser he is
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah i'm sure that that's
that's the reason bill gates so you're a
big believer in the transformative
effect of crypto rather than the
investments transition tim
[Laughter]
yes uh
not not a none like a big big believer
in the way because big believer in
crypto space means something else
because there is really big believers in
the crypto space i'm one of them i think
there's certain uh cultish aspects to
cryptocurrency
supporters where they're not able to see
not always able to approach things with
humility in an open mind well that's why
you need humor right that's why we need
to also poke fun at things yeah that's
what people don't realize the value in
that the value in like not taking
yourself so seriously you know who's
graded it the winklevoss twins are great
yeah they can make fun of stuff they get
it gary v is actually really good i was
texting with him he understand like
people that surprised me like they
people understand humor yeah and then
there's a lot of people that don't
understand humor that don't understand
the value because humor
at its core
at its base
all it seeks to do right
is to
i think just take down these sacred cows
yeah and it doesn't mean that the sacred
cows aren't sacred for a reason right
make a joke about jesus doesn't mean
that jesus wasn't this tremendously
impactful figure in history that
billions of people have put their faith
this doesn't mean that what it means is
that
what humor is
has his unique ability to do
is maybe
make
anything more
um
accessible to people i think it makes
things accessible
it takes kings off thrones yeah and
so people that believe so much a bitcoin
it can take a joke
the crypto world can take a joke yeah
and that's what that's why i'm a big fan
of you
that's why you i've been honored that
you make fun of me a few times and you
just grab it i love it i i like um and
when it's never
nasty no no or mean it's that's not it's
no i like uh smart people acting silly
versus silly people acting smart i like
that i'm not necessarily saying i'm
smart by a certain error on the side of
the silly because i i
that's why elon is also an inspiration
in that
despite everything else he's able to be
ridiculously silly well that's what i
like about him he he kind of pokes the
bear yeah and he doesn't get like uh
you've made fun of him a bunch doesn't
care does he doesn't care i mean not not
in the [ __ ] way i don't think he
knows who i am or
even knows that i've made fun of him oh
that i'm sure that's not true actually
but that'd be interesting i'll i'll
bring that up yeah i don't i don't know
that he i don't know if it's on his
radar yeah but i also think if it was on
his radar he wouldn't have
me drone striked i think he'd just
chuckle yeah exactly just chuck yeah
but yeah of course there's different
kinds of humor too there's this i mean
he's more in the uh
dad jokes silly memes category of humor
you're more like i'm going to do a tweet
thread on jazlane maxwell and how great
kim jong-un is
for the world and you know he's a he's a
he's a he's fat forward
yeah fat positive
bodybuilding is that a new fat forward
okay fat forward meaning that he
believes the future is fat yeah he's
he's a progressive fattest i agree
yeah
is it interesting to you you're in
worlds with a lot of very interesting
people this technology the robotics that
you're into
all of these countries right are are
are competing for
uh
i guess the word would be supremacy in a
lot of these arenas right
if china has the best technology china
is going to export it to everybody if
the us has the best technology the us is
going to export it to everybody there's
a lot of intellectual property concerns
there's a lot of
uh shadowy intelligence figures that
embed themselves
uh in institutions to try to
gain access to a lot of like highly
sensitive stuff that's being developed
and stuff like that
when you look at the landscape and you
see a country like china i've had
journalists on my show that have said
they believe that chinese very
influential in terms of like
they see a lot of american u.s corporate
interests
saying that we have to adopt a lot of
these
chinese technologies surveillance states
social credit scores things like that so
that we
can then
export them to the rest of the world we
have that hegemony
uh does that worry you at all that um
we're in a competition with an
authoritarian country
and that in order to beat them we may
have to become them
yeah that of course that worries me so
for example in the ai space
there's an uh recent report from the
united states that
we are now fully engaged in developing
autonomous weapons systems because china
is developing him and the argument was
made that
you know
we're willing to go into the race
for development of artificial
intelligence driven weapons because
that's for the good of the world because
china's doing it so if you don't do it
then they're going to do it and that's
how any kind of um
uh
you know bad thing happens so i'm really
worried about that because there's a lot
of people saying like you know
developing like robot dogs for example
aren't the the main concern here
actually it's it's drones
drones are terrifying and people have
there there's some kind of magic
connection that people have with legged
robots for example because it just
connects them to dogs and cats and
humans
but they're not actually very good at
uh committing violence uh compared to
drones trolls are great at it yeah
the best so the development of autonomy
currently most drones are remotely
controlled and the degree of autonomy is
minimal uh in terms of drones they're
doing uh we're moving into an arena
where you would have drones just
deciding
who and when to blow people up well it's
more and more it's greater and greater
degrees of automation so you would say
okay this location this building has a
terrorist
and
currently you have remote controlled
uh
operation of the drone to where you can
target very precisely that particular
building but then
you could start seeing
going to a place where okay
these are the set of locations we
believe the terrorists are located in
uh but let the drones start to decide
what is the most likely of those
locations right and then you get to more
and more automate the decision about
uh where
to launch the bomb or the missile and
then
then you start to expand the region of
automation with it now there will be a
set of drones that just monitor
the the presence of terrorists in a
particular city i mean it just becomes a
slippery slope where
you
you when you take the human out of the
loop of the decision-making you're you
start to commit
like
have the capacity to commit vastly
unethical things so yeah that really
worries me uh but also another thing
that kind of worries me is the the
warmongering so on the flip side
i've actually talked to a bunch of folks
that live in china
that
the americans have a way of uh seeing
the rest of the world that's kind of
flawed and america has the right to
answer for everything and how to live
life the the idea of freedom that we're
the good guys i mean every country has
this idea we have to be careful with
that because i think you have to try to
understand another culture
agreed so the it's not obvious to me
that um the chinese government is
absolutely
uh unequivocally like evil right they
have a very different culture i i've
interacted with folks uh on many in many
ways their culture is very different
like uh the value of uniqueness and
innovation for example
it's it's not
there in the same way that is in the
united states so
uh chinese folks and these engineers
chinese entrepreneurs
are more okay with copying
ideas right like
legally copying the way i would say bill
gates and microsoft copied ideas their
whole approach was
uh let's see what apple does and take
the best ideas from apple from from
netscape uh from from firefox from
google there they take ideas and they
try to make them better
that that kind of way of thinking is
just very fundamentally different from
the united states and if you say if you
constantly call them
um
out for like stealing or something like
that it's just constantly trying to
create tension where there doesn't
necessarily need to exist tension now
there's obviously a lot of aspects of uh
surveillance state that they're trying
to create that are
really worrying about human rights but
again i just feel like you have to lead
you have to start by trying to
understand them i think one of the
things that i like that they do
is that
when they have a problem
with uh
someone in their society we're usually a
very wealthy person like a billionaire
instead of
like
beating around the bush
they just disappear that person until
they can be re-educated
now it's dark it's dark but here's the
thing
i think
there's a
you know we bring all these billionaires
before congress and we like yell at them
we have like these midwestern
mom congressmen be like you're mike and
all this money and nobody's got any
money and it goes viral on twitter and
everyone goes shots queen but the
reality is instead of that why not
kidnap and torture these people
disappear
uh allegedly torture right
so i mean i'm not actually
so that that's
that's really
bad if that's happening well i'm also
i'm making light of it but i'm also
saying we seem anemic this is my the
serious point behind the joke yeah we
seem impotent
to control anybody in this country if
they've got enough capital yes china
does not
so so that's interesting and currently
china is making a lot of centralized
decisions that are actually good for its
society so there's a lot of people
discussing it's interesting
like if you said the human right if you
set the human rights violation aside for
a brief moment
if you look at the the markers in terms
of the economy in terms of actually the
quality of life across the population
uh it's it's increasing rapidly so the
problem is
you know that's the problem with
communism like you could do a lot of
good for in the short term but it's a
slippery slope of power that's right
that corrupts people
yeah i
my biggest worry with china is if
there's an overbearing government is not
the disappearing of billionaires it's
the
the fear that overtakes the populace
where they can't speak up it's the it's
the self-uh self-censorship it's not
censorship it's self-censorship what do
you think people get wrong about
vladimir putin
uh this is a very touchy subject on this
particular program
well what do you mean by
that i have no well you've become now
that larry king has passed now you
become the new larry king that is true
that is unequivocally true and no one
would deny that what did they get wrong
well because he's a historical figure
yeah and a present figure
you uh growing up in the soviet union
you have an understanding
of him maybe as a leader that other
people don't right from the west or from
outside one of the things i was highly
critical of
um was when
our government our cia
was like fomenting coups in the ukraine
encircling putin encircling russia and
then
when putin would respond to that we'd go
what a monster but i mean if he was
doing that to us we'd have the exact
same reaction this is what i mean about
propaganda and narratives emerging right
so
however that being said it does seem
like
uh there's a consolidation of power that
is unhealthy
um
so i i'll say one
just building on your previous point of
the cia and the fsb and the kgb
there's a game being played there this
game being played in the shadows and
there's a bunch of people that are very
good at this game
and i think what i could say about
vladimir putin is i think he's very good
at this game and i don't like i
personally
don't like that such a game is played
that anything's done in the shadows that
there's this manipulation that's
happening there's this game b
just spying at each other the
cyber attacks in the modern world
stealing information
um manipulating information like
you know creating narratives
that
get uh like the american populist pissed
off about something and then right
america creating narratives in europe
that gets europe pissed off at russia
all those things that that that's a game
that's the game of geopolitics uh henry
kissinger is somebody who was incredibly
good at this game and the fact that like
such a game has to be played is deeply
dishonest and destructive to the world
so i i i mean but that it's a
fascinating game
and what troubles me most of course is
like we know so little about it there's
just a giant number of conspiracy
theories but they're just
uh
flirting at the door of truth they're
not really you can't you can't it's not
it's not trans these organizations that
transp are not transparent unfortunately
so i just want to you know say that
um there is kind of in russia a
discussion especially amongst young
folks and it's certainly in the united
states
that sounds similar to the way people
analyze donald trump which is saying
that putin is dumb
that putin
is just a lucky idiot
and um that's not true
well there's a lot of people that
believe this and i i what i
personally believe is he's a very
intelligent man
and um
on in terms of the game that we're just
referring of course the other thing i
should mention that people might know
the reason i find him fascinating as a
historical figure
is he's able
he's very intelligent in conversation
so he's able to analyze the world
in very interesting ways and there's
leaders aren't always that
intelligent in conversation or
just as like you know as analysts of
history analysts of the present
geopolitics of the world
and
which you would appreciate humor
right and
like
dark humor right
so that's what makes him really
fascinating to me
um obviously what also makes me
fascinating is that i bel
he's been in power for 20 years now 20
21 years and i think power's changed
them and it's unclear to me in which
direction but it has
i think he was a different man at the at
the beginning of his rule
i don't want to say too much on this
podcast and sort of what that is because
it requires a lot more context right but
there was uh
let me just say that i as somebody was
in the soviet union
in the 90s and then the collapse of the
soviet union
that was true suffering and uncertainty
that that was a really really difficult
time
and what putin did
is uh there's a
significant economic recovery
as that started the 21st century with
him at the rule and so
that's why still a lot of people see him
as a powerful leader because he saved
russia from the collapse of the soviet
union from like the destructive aspects
of the the soviet union yeah from the
looting yeah from what's happening but
also the financial system was in is is
wrecked yeah and um there's the
oligarchs just kind of more and more
yeah and that's one of the difficult
realities you have to
see in or think about
when you think about putin is the
context in which he operates the level
of corruption all around
there is some aspect to russia where a
strong leader
in the short term is necessary
to keep um
the corruption at bay
now that's a dark reality and i don't
think it's a
scrim
i think all revolutions are really
painful that doesn't mean you shouldn't
go through with them
but if you just analyze the situation as
it currently is
russia is in a very difficult place and
it as a human being just for me it hurts
my heart because i
know the culture
of the 20th century the soviet union
there was so much love for mathematics
and science for poetry and music
there's something about the world war
where
tens of millions of people die that
creates some of the most beautiful art
great amazing and
and uh so much of that
um i think it's just a beautiful place
that
culturally can flourish
and be part of the world and it
currently is not nearly um as much as a
part of the world as it could be so
science and
uh tech there's just so little
communication between united states and
the rest of the world with with russia
what do you think the next when putin
steps down what does the future of that
political system look like
this is the scary thing it's it's uh
it's not good
it's not that's why a lot of people say
well
my life is good now
and and they're afraid of the
uncertainty of putin stepping down
would you have him as a guest on the
show
yes of course do you think he would do
it yes
really yeah when will he do it
this is you're the larry king soon
interesting yeah
do you think he will do a podcast tour
well he will also do my show and red
scare yeah so uh and a bunch of other
shows that's scare that's a good one
yeah
well there you go from there yeah
probably joe rogan first
it would be great if he did rogan yeah i
well i told i i told joe to be a
translator so he speaks pretty good
english actually but he doesn't speak
english
publicly because right you kind of have
to
only needs to understand one word yes
ivermectin
uh he would probably say that there's
not enough love for the russian vaccine
or you know there's a giant what is the
russian vaccine
i i see you brought me onto the show for
the scientific analysis of uh
synovac is china right what is the
russian fact
uh yeah i don't actually know the
details about it i just do i know the
name of it even it's sputnik five or
something five or something is it i'll
get boosted with sputnik five is it uh
bank you fact check me
kovacs
not that's not the right no that's not
the russian one ben
what kind of
mediocre research team do you have here
i mean he's not a research team
yeah thank you
all right
[Laughter]
um
who's he working for that's the real
question well that's he's the jesuit
maxwell the pri operation you're the
[ __ ] you have a lot more
intelligence in him
a lot of people didn't even make
resolutions this year and you know what
i get it but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't still find a way to shake
things up whether it's by switching up
your workout routine or going someplace
new whatever way you want to challenge
yourself this year there's no better way
to do it than with a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears raycon
wireless earbuds are the best way to
bring audio with you no matter how much
you shake things up literally no matter
how much you shake they will not fall
out of your ears their everyday earbuds
look feel and sound better than ever i
hate the other earbuds they're too
expensive they fall out they're easy to
lose
these air buds are great there's several
modes you have awareness mode when you
need to listen to your surroundings so
you can jog and make sure that you're
with everything and enjoy the music it's
so important
i love the raycon earbuds they never
fall out of my ears and you know me i
shake violently all the time
and raycon earbuds never fall out that's
really what we're selling now this month
with this ad read
ray cons don't fall out of your ears
a lot of things are going to happen in
society
in the next months you know and it's
going to involve people shaking
but one good thing is as you're stroking
out on the floor one thing you won't
lose is your ability to enjoy music
i should also mention sorry for the
interruptions
uh
in the rain they're good too
so if you're shaking on control you're
shaking in the rain you put raycons in
your ears and you enjoy uh
you know a little toto
raycons offer eight hours of play time
in 32 hour battery life they are
priceless right you get quality audio at
half the price of other premium audio
brands it's no wonder raycon's everyday
earbuds have over forty eight thousand
five star reviews
right now listeners can get fifteen
percent off their raycon order at
buyredcon.com tim that's buy ratecon dot
com slash tim to save fifteen percent on
raycon's by raycon.com
tim
the best morning routine starts the
night before many of you know mudwater
you've heard rogan talking about their
coffee alternatives made with organic
ingredients they rejuvenate
you love mud water i love mud water it's
delicious
the new
their new rest blend promotes rest and
relaxation so you wake up rested each
ingredient in the evening rest blend was
added for a purpose they have
ashwagandha to support relaxation from
everyday stress turkey tail and rishi to
support a healthy immune
environment
immune system
valerian root and passion flower you're
doing so good at this tim yeah for
flavor
tumeric for exercise induced soreness
cinnamon
for antioxidants we even recommend
pairing your evening cup with a bedtime
story the three little pigs little red
riding hood but here's the reality folks
everyone's doing this mud water
yeah i can't leave my house without
someone
coming up to me and trying to kill me
because i won't listen to them about mud
water so i finally started to
i love it i drink it ben drinks it
it's great now you like it as well what
do you like about it
i like that it's spelled m-u-d-w-t-r
backslash wtr it's very very innovative
they get it they get it that's essential
i actually honestly love i love i love
like that taste of caffeine and they do
it like really
um well it's nice what they do no like
uh it tastes like there should be a ton
of calories in it and it's not it tastes
good but you there's no guilt there's no
guilt you're not guilty about it you
know you know sometimes if i eat
like a
something naughty
like ice cream or some type of treat
i feel guilty about it yeah but if i
drink mud water i feel rested yeah and
relax
so go and get mud water what are you
waiting for it really supports the
podcast it supports your immune system
and everything it's easy
use code tim at mudwater.com guys do it
you're gonna love it it is good tim at
mudwater.com tim they sponsor the
podcast
they're on board they love it
you have to show them now that you are
powerful consumers go out there don't
make a fool of me go out there go to
mudwater.com tim and get the mud water
because
you wake up and you're like oh i've
slept
that's the difference yeah
people can't sleep right now
do you understand too much in their mind
well they hate the themselves and their
communities and when water fixes all
that water will fix it you sleep
people right now are in a loveless
marriage they've destroyed their
relationship with their children they're
they don't have a job that they find
fulfilling they have no spiritual basis
for existence
they're just eating and [ __ ] going
through the motions completely divorced
from any higher realm of knowledge uh
they've been divorced from honor from
nature they uh exist as kind of a pod
person seriously as kind of a science
experiment like a potato that people
watch things grow out of and they're
only
waiting for the inevitability of the
foods they eat and the drinks they
consume to ravage their body with cancer
and they die
but
if they have mud water that's
now good
mud water
use the code tim for five dollars off
your evening ritual kit mudwater your
dreams deserve it
who do you think is the brains honestly
jeffrey inches line yeah
neither well here's what i mean by that
gizlane's father was intelligence
gislane was very schooled in the world
of intelligence right and you know
understanding like
what intelligence is is the maintenance
of relationships yeah essentially right
and having leverage over people and
how relationships are structured and
who has the upper hand at any given time
and that could change and blah blah blah
and you know so just lane understood
that her dad was this media mogul robert
maxwell was murdered um her sisters are
in tech it's an intelligence family um
epstein was a you know kind of
you know from many people that have met
him
sort of
by no means brilliant guy right like he
was not this
amazing intellect however he had a
very good understanding of
people
their their
appetites their proclivities their
weaknesses um surrounding underage women
surrounding
illicit streams of money where they
wanted their money hidden um i'm sure
surrounding many other things as well he
was he seemed to be very good at that i
think the way that they both functioned
was a team
of people that
you know ran this very i think epstein
was the public face
of it as a philanthropist
as an investor
um i think just lane was just a
socialite
but
uh not just a socialite you know to the
public just to socialize but
behind the scene she was a madam she was
a pimp she was an access agent she
connected uh jeffrey to people that were
very powerful in the uk and and other
places that were friends of her father
um and they they had an operation that
was based on
entrapping blackmailing gaining leverage
over
very powerful
politicians so do you think there was an
intelligence connection to all of this
mossad it was absolutely a messiah here
with
with eric on this oh it was a mossad
operation but that doesn't mean the cia
didn't know about it and give it its
blessing you know the cia ran operations
like this in the 80s in the 90s uh these
honeypot blackmail operations are not
terribly new they were pioneered by the
mafia
i mean this has been going back for a
very long time you know but like have so
many powerful people involved
rich people oh yeah sure i mean that's
the point
the point is to
all of these institutions whether it's
council on foreign relations or all
these things where people think are very
like nefarious whatever it is bohemian
grove or skull and bones all these
things where they really are they just
create
a consensus amongst the wealthiest and
most powerful people on the planet and
that consensus becomes our foreign
policy our domestic policy our corporate
policy
so it's just creating a consensus so if
you put a bunch of young guys at yale
together
and whatever they do whatever bonding
activities they do to become
closer
or if you put them out in the woods in
monterey california at bohemian grove or
if you put them on an island committing
crimes
what this does is this fosters a sense
of
you know mutually assured destruction
uh a sense of um
you know
how homogeneous
you know ruling a homogeneous ruling
class i i agree by the way i should
mention for the record ben is wearing a
harvard shirt
that he was given to by a fat woman
who's no longer fat because she had a
gastric bypass
if you were more fat forward yes like
your friend you wouldn't even make that
comment but i mean i think i'm right
about this where it's like it's an
intelligence op
they were the face of it as they moved
into the digital world it became less
necessary to have these physical
honeypots yeah you tweeted about this
that the the the true tragedy of jesus
maxwell is that it's just yet another
human being losing out to automation
it's they're being replaced by ai no
matter what you think of jeffrey inches
lane is a real issue human trafficking
used to involve humans yeah
there's a human cost
this is absolutely the case
do you think i'm wrong about anything
i've said
well
i'm uncomfortable with the intelligent
connection you know why
uh
so there's a book about just lane's
father called israel's super spy yeah so
the father is definitely shady okay so
the father's in the massage we no i
don't know about the mossad thing you
don't know about that there's something
about the suicide or whatever the death
but it's kind of widely
uh believed you know he was at the
funeral and i forgot if this big is
really premier like i think it's wise
but there's a difference between for
example if i have a conversation with
putin am i part of the fsb no but that's
an important
you know elon musk was once at a party
with just lane maxwell at the same party
and she's everybody was at a party with
jesus maxwell well yes and so the
question is what is the depth of the
connection
well it's it's there's book there's a
book about it i mean it's it's i have a
lot of books about a lot of stuff to
show well but written by seymour hirsch
i mean ben get the title of the book up
right get to what is the title of the
book written by one of america's
greatest pulitzer prize-winning
journalists
okay
yeah but also seymour hirsch wrote
something it might not have been a book
but seymour hirsch wrote something as
well
about
about him but but again it's there's an
entire book about it so there is
evidence no i know so um
i'm under-informed
about this topic i just have a general
wariness of calling people intelligence
yeah so because it's such a tempting
like whenever i in my mind
feel a temptation
uh to see a conspiracy theory in
something like i i uh has so what do you
think it would be if it wasn't
intelligence what and let's say it's not
the mossad we'll back that out yeah
which it was but it's also cia and the
mossad and saudi intelligence are all
like really tight and mi6 they're like
bros yeah so
and then there's like iranian
intelligence
and
russian intelligence and syrian
intelligence and they're like
cool they're like friends yeah so this
is a view of the world right with the
intelligence organizations is ultra
competent
i yes they are okay well this is my my
view
is they're not ultra complex not all of
them they're exceptionally well funded
they're large organizations that have a
lot of people pushing paper and they are
pretty effective a lot of things but
there's these are not the a students of
the world i believe okay let's the a
students don't run the world c students
do
you don't have to be an a student if
you're willing to kill someone
truly if you're a c student and you're
willing to put a gun in someone's mouth
yes it's actually probably
just as good as having an a
what would you say it if it's not an
intelligence blackmail operation what
would you
uh say that it could be
i would say it's
one charismatic person
jeffrey epstein yeah
that was
evil and committed things um but that's
a great everyone listening to this is
you sound crazy on this show which is
why i enjoy doing it
no not everybody i'm not i'm i'm a
little bit playing devil's advocate here
so i'm not don't fully believe this but
there's a there's a sense
where i feel that
there's an important distinction to draw
jeffrey epstein being a complete
manufacturing manifestation of an
intelligence agency versus as one
charismatic evil person becomes more and
more successful individualist like yeah
on an individual level you start meeting
powerful people and then intelligence
does
necessarily the entire intelligence
agency right the these these
intelligence agencies are bureaucracies
but they do have within them
fiefdoms and factions of power you have
bad actors you have people that are
outside of the agency officially that
have all the skills and know all the
people so it's not necessarily as easy
as going like it's the entire cia behind
any of these things right but there are
groups of people all the intelligence
agencies do is they work for
billionaires essentially they work for
american corporate interests it's what
the cia does they've overthrown
governments at the behest of american
corporate interests this is the cia
works for wealthy people they
essentially are the information
the muscle
and yes
where we cannot do things overtly
uh with our military uh and with u.s
policy and get things passed through
congress you have a shadow organization
that's able to do that that's not
terribly controversial right i mean
that's pretty well known if you look at
all the coups you know in other
countries that are provable coups may be
in this country that are well what's
what's important for me to understand
what this is i don't think it's
controversial the question is the scale
at which how many people are involved
how much
uh
like how much of it is at the core what
the cia does versus this is a few people
well the core of what the cia does
probably is largely
you know they gather a lot of
information and analyze it yeah but then
they're like the core of any business
right so if you looked at walmart the
core of walmart is you going in and
buying socks and someone taking your
money you know but then there's a group
of people in walmart
making decisions and charting the
direction of the company and what
they're gonna do for the next five or
ten years so i think the core of these
institutions can be relatively benign
but the there's again power factions
within them that are not all homogeneous
right there's people in the cia that had
no idea what was going on there's people
that would be disgusted by it there's
people that would be repulsed by it
there's no getting around this fact
blackmail has been uh an essential part
of the recruitment
of
agents
it's been an essential part of
maintaining relationships with people
this is how
intelligence people have often found
leverage to gain information yeah that
is true yeah that's very true the my
question is
how
um
is that increasing or decreasing the
amount of that being done so ultimately
my question is about so whenever you
think intelligence
is running
the most powerful people in the world
they're blackmailed and everything is
being controlled by by certain very
powerful figures you you very naturally
lead to a cynicism about the future of
the world that deeply troubles me so
like i want to land an optimism like
with people have you tried drugs
uh no drugs
not all of them drugs are very good for
this
because they are mechanism well they
make you feel a way that reality might
not no i don't think so i think drugs
i'm not saying everything's cynical i'm
not saying everybody's controlled what i
am saying is that
one cannot bury their head in the sand
when there is a
island
and a mansion in new york city that has
recording equipment you have a guy that
was let off the first time with a very
sweetheart deal who's piling around with
prime ministers kings and president
it's the definition of this looks bad
but i would argue as the nature gaze
into the abyss and the biscuits is back
into you i would argue if all you study
is the jeffrey epstein case yeah you
will see devils everywhere i don't think
there's devils everywhere so this is the
burden
of the great that's the cunan was that's
also i mean
i love alex but he's nuts when you
constantly analyze this stuff you just
it's that's all you see is red
understood and so i if you don't see any
red that's also a problem if there's no
devils you go well i don't think there's
any devils the that's an issue
there's definitely a balance strike
there i
i it seems unsupported
that this is one evil person and another
evil person together
with no larger no no the the the network
builds over time right and they
a lot of it is
parties and handshakes and so on and you
greet each other politicians
i'm sure so okay one one thing
that seems to be the case
because i've known people that interact
with jeffrey epstein
he seems he completely deluded them like
the charisma is there and it doesn't
have to do with money or
uh women
at uh at the core level it has to do
with straight up in the room together
yeah and so
i just believe that one charismatic guy
can do a lot of damage in this world
without first
sort of
being manufactured as a strategic
deployment onto the united states by
some intelligence agency now over time
as he interacts with more and more
powerful people he probably met he
probably got some phone calls and
probably had some meetings i don't even
think i would say that he was deployed i
think that
i don't believe
that the way these agencies necessarily
operate is that we're thinking of them
as
you know custodians of national interest
which i don't think they are right i
think
they are kind of
work for hire organizations where
there's certain people in those
countries that have a lot of money that
have an idea about the way things should
be run that you know kind of use these
agencies i don't necessarily think that
like all of these agencies all the time
are focused on
the betterment of any one particular
nation state
i think there's a certain group of
people that have enough money and enough
power that use these agencies as ways to
sustain that
position in society so i think epstein
whether it was in tel aviv or in london
or in manhattan was having conversations
with these people whose loyalty is
really not to
any particular country but it's to their
own interests i just have to say that i
am really troubled
on a personal level yeah that there's a
lot of people i respect
that when they were in a room with
jeffrey epstein we're not able to see
through the we're not able to see evil
would not have the integrity no because
they were looking at [ __ ] well this is
this is the this is the thing is
i mean maybe i'm bill different this is
isn't that like a ford thing or
something uh
built uh yeah
uh
rock
chevy
i i just think you can't let [ __ ] or
money delude you and and destroy your
integrity integrity should be above all
else and when i see
that not being the case with jeffrey
epstein um like people that have spoken
with jeff epstein that really troubles
me
that
his
charisma and manipulation revealed the
people who lack integrity in my view now
i could be naive
because
you could be the next jeffrey epstein
and ben could be the next jizzly maxwell
and here i am doing this beautiful
podcast and i'm even a fan so maybe it's
your charisma well nobody's giving me um
an island nobody's giving me an island
and nobody's giving me the largest uh
one of the largest uh pieces of real
estate in manhattan this is also the
problem when you look at this um you
know as uh just this independent uh
thing uh you look at well why did les
wexner was the head of the limited
brands gift
jeffrey epstein these massive
insanely desirable pieces of real estate
uh is one in new york city right
um
what is the connection there that's that
that connection has not been proven yeah
yeah that one yeah what people have
spoken about that's really shady
that's just a shady connection right so
you have this guy
who is a well-established human
trafficker and you have his biggest
benefactor
uh financially not questioned at all in
any meaningful way
about this
i mean you can be as as averse to
conspiracy theories as you want
but a lot of times unfortunately they
just become the news
and this has kind of become the news
yeah yeah it's become the news but i
understand your thing i think your
thing's valid
the q anon movement which is psychotic
people whose minds had melted
when they got a few nuggets of truth and
then they concocted
disney-esque
childish stories
about good and evil because they wanted
everything in life to have
the clarity
and certitude of religion and they
created this thing where everyone in
hollywood's evil and everyone's a
pedophile and then
dead people are going to come back and
jfk junior was it was a very religious
movement
that's what happens to people when they
see devils everywhere and they're unable
to
uh differentiate fact from fiction and
on the other side there's similar things
in the the scientific community has
really been disappointing to me about
the level of arrogance how they dismiss
every conspiracy they just dismiss
basically everything is a conspiracy
theory that's not
like
very narrowly defined a public policy i
watched your interview with the ceo
pfizer that guy the greek guy who owns a
diner and what i like about that
interview
was that he was a um
no but he's just you've offended the
greeks the italians diner
even though he's the ceo of pfizer he
literally owns a diner in a story of
queens where he brings out spanakopita
and yells at his his
wife and their nephews who work at the
diner yeah by the way that's the reality
i'm guessing his son is a fan of yours
because uh his son mentioned the podcast
he likes he's a fan of this podcast
or my podcast and i'm guessing they're a
fan of me i mean very smart people
listen to you that doesn't mean they
come over to me yeah they should that's
the this
yeah that's the the next step but my
answer to him is less listening to lex
friedman and more getting people
mozzarella sticks in your father's day
to get back to work because when i see
that guy you go oh he's a ceo of fisher
i go this is a guy who owns a diner yeah
and it's a struggling diner
but it's good they get they make they
make good they get mileage out of the
coleslaw let me finish up with this ben
how long have we done we've done a while
can i just say
before you finish up yes
how much i love ben
he's really
the best part of your podcast that is a
that's not true but ben is uh no i love
ben ben is essential for me to do what i
do and he's just a kind soul he's a
console he's a good hearted person
he's a good-hearted person and he works
very very hard
and
he's one of these people where i'm lucky
to have a ben not everybody has a band
right
so i'm lucky to have him now that being
said
he must be watched
very closely harvard he must be you know
who else wore a harvard sweatshirt
jeffrey epstein yeah is that the is that
the reason yeah
yeah but ben must be watched like
everyone they must be surveilled yeah
so you do like the chinese government
after all i
love the chinese government and they're
advertising on my podcast next month
i no here's what i say about them
they're going to be tough to beat
yeah they're going to be hard to beat
because they're willing to do things
that we might not be willing to do
and that's
you know
i don't know
uh can i read you a poem yes
because this poem makes me think of you
yes
i i like this lip i i haven't even heard
it but i'm excited and then i'll read
you a poem
so you go first okay
there's a cat in the hat yeah all right
well this is probably my favorite
bukowski poem and it it's exactly about
you oh that's very sweet there's a kind
of uh
buckowski-esque aspect to your career to
who you are yeah okay
it's called bluebird
there's a bluebird in my heart that
wants to get out but i'm too tough for
him i say stay in there
i'm not going to let anybody see you
there's a blue bird in my heart that
wants to get out
but i pour whiskey on him and inhale
cigarette smoke and the [ __ ] and the
bartenders and the grocery clerks never
know that he's in there
there's a bluebird in my heart that
wants to get out
but i'm too tough for him i say stay
down
do you want to mess me up you want to
screw up the works you want to blow my
book sales in europe
there's a blue bird in my heart that
wants to get out but i'm too clever
i only let him out at night sometimes
when everybody's asleep
i say i know that you're there so don't
be sad
then i put him back
but he's singing a little in there
i haven't quite let him die
and we sleep together like that with our
secret pact and it's nice enough to make
a man weep
but i don't weep do you
charles because that's grant palm now i
want i want to do a poem for you yeah
that was i love that
it's an encouragement to let your uh
the bluebird out yeah
it's it's a little bit of love
okay i mean
i want to find this one
i'm almost scared
are you buckowski fan yeah
badass [ __ ]
bad attitude
nails done hair done
ass too
your baby daddy [ __ ] me and sucking
me
he don't answer you [ __ ] that's because
of me
[Laughter]
who's who's the
author of this uh masterpiece young
miami
okay
well thank you so much for having me on
your podcast thank you for having me
thanks friedman everyone